en joséphine de beauharnais c'est joli
non
salut françois à je suis ni du est en
retard aux îles magnifiques tenues julie
laisser mon déguisement pour la grande
farandole c'est vrai j'avais
complètement oublié ah bon mais c'est
pourtant le jour le plus gai de l'île
aux enfants et je sais tu as raison il
faut que je me dépêche
j'ai complètement oublié mon déguisement
cas les tours 10 je suis sûr que casimir
est tellement excité qu'il n'a pas dormi
de la nuit
je file chez moi je mets mon déguisement
je serai de retour pour le début de la
grande farandole pêche trois trios de
givet
bonjour chers amis monsieur du snap je
vois que vous êtes prêt à vous aussi oui
et comment retrouver vous
super va votre enthousiasme ne m'étonne
pas du tout cher ami je sais que vous
avez un goût particulièrement sûr et moi
je constate une fois de plus que vous ne
vous intéressez qu'à vous même
mais pourquoi dites vous ça parce que
vous ne vous êtes même pas aperçus que
moi aussi je suis déguisé aux eaux par
donner moi chers amis je suis vraiment
trop égoïstes et coûté
au met mais c'est casimir
il dort
les yeux complètement fermée mais alors
ma chère amie s'il marche en dormant
c'est qu'il est somnambule
oui mais il faut le répéter non surtout
pas se renier ne savez vous pas qu'il ne
faut jamais réveillé un somnambule
brusquement et risquent de mourir sur le
coup c'était pouvant table je ne fais
pas dire voici les snobs génie
mais voilà j'ai vite fait
monsieur 10,9 pas mal votre déguisement
écoute france - que pensez-vous des
milieux très bien mais ça n'est pas le
moment de parler déguisement oui l'heure
est grave que se passe-t-il
semblait bouleversé tous les deux
écoutez façon je vais vous expliquer
voilà calinon monsieur distingue ce
n'est pas la peine regarde toi même fond
noir
s'alarmer mais casimir marche en dormant
mais alors il est somnambule oui vous
comprenez maintenant pourquoi nous
sommes émus et bien sûr mais c'est
terrible mais je suis sûr que c'est
parce qu'elle n'a pas dormi de la nuit
tu crois écoutez il faut absolument
faire quelque chose oui mais quoi
bonjour à tous
vous auriez pu au moins vous déguiser
mais je suis déguisée au pardonnez moi
je n'ai pas vu la différence avec vos
tenues habituelles écoutez monsieur du
snob je vous en prie nous avons en son
nom en tête d'autres penser que les
déguisements des données futé oui vous
avez raison françois bon mais pourquoi
mais que se passe-t-il et bien casimir
et sans bulles ils marchent en dormant
fait incroyable j'y pense vous avez dû
le croiser à moi mais pas du tout si
messi mais s'il veut vous venez du
chemin des biches riz et bien comme nous
venons de voir casino s'y engager je ne
les ai pas vus et alors ils auraient ils
auraient disparu quand il faut partir
leurs chercheurs écoutez chacun rentre
chez lui où il retire son déguisement
nous et nous organisons les recherches
près d'accord d'accord rendez vous ici
[Musique]
oh
or julie alors rien rien monsieur du
snob échec complet au
raid mais aucune trace en casimir sarah
l'armée mais qu'en fait vous pourquoi
vous avez vos déguisements la grande
farandole va commencer à les imiter mais
nous cherchons partout où nous étions
très inquiets et pourquoi mais casimir
parce que tu es somnambule
oui tu marches aux deux romans - mais
pas du tout pas du tout sisi casimir et
nous avons tous vu traverser le jardin
et les yeux fermés et les bras tendus en
avant ouais et alors comme ça oui je
m'entraîne elle pour la grande farandole
c'est la position idéale regardez allez
on va tant pis pour les costumes musique
à cenon pas casimir on n'ose pas la
farandole comme ça n'est pas vu comment
on fait maison s'être là dedans c'est
très bien c'est mon grand tu m'as appris
à rester comme ça là nous à la hausse
non les mains oui laisser aller si
on se croyait que c'était comme ça
enfin c'est sa farandole
au non non non moi je répété pourront
rien
[Musique]